Did you like my video or did you follow me?
Remember to like and share this video with your friends.
I love you.
Hi Bro!
Good morning!
oh hi you gozaima we're better oh my god did you hear that voice crack I was
embarrassing didn't even mean to put that's me put my put myself in my
oh yo oh yo
good morning I've won I've won I don't know how to say it good morning good
evening and good afternoon I'm your host Johnny cattle and there's children
screaming in the background but don't worry about that too much folks that
they're playing at home thank you for the super chat M&S 180 small
investment no keep that wait until I've contacted the company I need to figure
out which one is there's a company that worked with other VTubers that did the
old tape a toy you know I'm saying you know I'm saying and today short stream
tomorrow I will release my schedule I had to mess up my schedule and audition
these short streams what can I just say thank you I have slept for ten hours
yep it's true I've had ten hours hours I'm so happy loud ass stinger oh god was
it sorry sorry if you got the bubble popped in your ear I got ten hours of
sleep so yeah ten hours and twenty-five keys bro 25 case of right who's got the
fucking Tenga used to renew I don't care I need it for the ASMR okay I need it
to do an ASMR stream you understand later okay right now though right now
but yes I've had ten hours of sleep I'm just waking up the now I've got a cup
of tea don't know if you can hear my knee my nails against the teacup but I
don't think so I just want to say it is a storm I can't and you know what
happens in storms internet's can go down during storms I am so nervous my
internet is gonna just right and then that's it that's the end of stream and
I'm like okay so we're just playing a giffy cute little game oh my god my voice
cannot stop cracking it's cracked twice down you aim I think it's because I've
been like asleep with my mouth open I don't know like some people can sleep
really gracefully I'm that's how I sleep I don't know about you I'm not a sheebie
put it that way she be has very peaceful sleep pattern me however I be
farting I be moaning I be talking and my mom hates it because the creeps are
out and I drill literal girls in it yeah I like Alice so much like with using
for my hands my feet my armpits and most of all my mouth it's where it was all
molecules so no the sleep talking just like how we play cute crazy I was like
so she be if you didn't know she be did a Twitter space where she was snoozing
right and I'm like do you not fart in your sleep like aren't you worried I
think I'd be absolutely terrified I'm not being funny I did like a hunker of a
far right before stream because it got stuck in me you know once I was snoozing
all that gas belt up I did a little bit but my even my stomach size went down
after that but do you kick your arms and legs over the place too yes I'm a very
violent sleeper but I can go for a very deep sleep I said I can get 10 hours if
you enable me look at the lava lamp in the background you can see my cursor
yeah you can see my cursor right so this is just like a kid give Giffy game
called the coin game I'm not really choose your player a male or I like how
the male is in this thingy and then the females are actually outside she's not
even in it I didn't realize how bad others clothing options oh my god I'm
gonna pick this for no oh she moved birthday mode a birthday party for you
fun and wax so you can play games when the money runs out just hit the money
grabber teleport around island from smartwatch no health curfew or parents
to worry about birthday mode is unlimited mode survival excuse me what I
thought this was a game about being in an arcade survival mode you've got health
and energy bar
right let's just do that I guess starting birthday mode it'll delete any well
we've got any progress I've never played this before it just looks like a cute
arcade like date thing why is a Merry Christmas Merry Christmas hello hi
you're lost do not fly to her survival literally the zombies gonna show up
and come for us the old arcades were jungles I tell you literally free for
all their own kidding you can press F to pick up items and put them in your
inventory happy birthday scrawny enter here
traveling carnival games rides food and fun for the whole family step right up
okay we are here new text message press tab okay now uncle so happy birthday
kid oh thanks for purchasing the coin well I'm not happy birthday is it smartwatch
tutorial right wrap it up wrap it up right left click center randomizing the
play tables and coin pushers one at a time happy birthday I maybe should have
played this on my birthday what don't like that oh I didn't like that hold on
they jumping me what left click to grab press F not yours I can touch okay I can
touch them I'm not sure I like Larry's oh my god can you hear this oh my god it's
five days of Freddy's how does this happen what does that even say I won
something I won the bomb oh this is terrifying sorry I'm sure this is
supposed to be like cute and funny sure I'll take a jawbreaker
not a restroom I'm not very experienced going to an arcade oh now what I'm just
to grab it from the air I feel like you guys would be better the arcade than me
hold on a minute I've like never played this before they put you in a room of
money and fly at your face cute and funny like in me real though yeah this is
just a casual game there's gonna be more endurance next week
fucking relax I thought it was a Wayne's game right I seem to kind of come out I'm
stuck here great job you won $57 I know this is fine nice a Freddy's I will
flashlight fuck it let's get a spray right click drink oh it's meant and you
wait the packaging's too similar they love to do that were you cheesy is that
with an F I'm British I can't say that we can't say that in Britain oh no I've
got to wax the pinata on my own this game is very dark maybe it's supposed to
be like that local whether you a fool all the wee grandma and it in in the
corner where you random box oh to send the chair I would be funny if this is a
surprise horror game and what fucking ends when these guys are jump scares
where's your parents ooh what do we want to win what there's nothing cuddly like
you I want to win you a piggy you're not Peggy though right controversial take
they should have put a wee bit more I don't know I don't know I guess and see
like my whole I was very forthcoming is that a salt rock oh my god bitches love
salt rocks I'm not bitches for once but sure oh my god what do you even go to
first Teddy and the ticket-eaters shows all night one point prizes all the
tickets will be counted for exit no right so can I know get some jelly beans
click here purchase give me some fun jelly bean eat yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum okay it's a very unique game right meant you right
we're not thirsty when official Dunkle merch here collect all five cards plus
all right all right let's do it let's do it I did interact let's do it okay I can't
interact are you sweet no I'm like I'm a soft lock wait I'm I'm stuck I'm actually
just bro right get that in there we're playing the first game sure what is the
oh my god it's the Gamber oh okay another one do again do again I'm
addicted these ones are so good they're like so addictive right if it comes in
drop it because then it'll be out by the time it finishes get it and then out and
then oh wait it did that wrong look we're doing it we're doing it hi mommy have
you been good I got ten hours of sleep and we're playing arcade games these
ones are like for the people who are addicted to gambler waiting for final
push yes so dramatic
oh nothing I suck at this game who are these people that move joystick left or
right sure what right now I get me out of here right continue get me out of
here play this wait escape isn't escape
off we're getting the sake I'm stuck in this oh no I've just been sexy bro I'm
stuck I stuck in this fucking game oh hold on a minute
oh no we need to go through all six yes and then I'll get out there's no escape
I'm just spamming it no stop giving me more I mean it's working though see this
is why you should gamble in video games only like not real money because it
doesn't matter right okay stop giving me more okay thank you no I don't want to
play again thank you geez oh my gosh I just have to put them in inventory 44
tickets all I had to do is give it money okay treasure in the sand that like
so cute insert card yeah oh I can't I'm too tall for once I don't think I've
ever said that in my real life before I'm too tall don't touch the shovel hand
don't don't touch the shovel handle I mean sure why not Danny do anything with
the money sorry Danny do anything with the audio
well my time sure would be a shame if I fuck it up no no what are you doing oh
my time I got 20 tickets okay curious simple I like it oh there's a bit more
coming no I just took it too soon for the game I keep up right was this one big
oh press I never read the instructions fast enough I got kicked out of my
steam account waiting my discord won't open hello can you hear me can you hear
me at least I've been kicked out my steam account I can't even open a feature
studio I'm just a fucking black screen my PC shut down twice oh my god I don't
know what to do if I fucking png wait actually someone commissioned an artwork
of me hold on I'm just gonna fucking steal it I'm sorry I'm gonna steal it
feature feature show is not letting me in let me I don't know why it's acting like
I wasn't just on it literally 50 seconds ago how do I put a picture of me on
screen breathe hold on hold on I put a picture of me on screen okay special
shout out to like there you go mommy's on screen there we go I think this might
be a yeah it's just so scuffed look at me and gamm gamm the meds no it's fine
you're okay you're okay I'm trying to refresh my discord and my discord isn't
working oh my god
bro please steam please work with me why is it acting like I wasn't online five
minutes ago I'm gonna fucking vomit I'm so sorry you're gonna vomit I'm gonna
vomit I think this might just turn into a yeah false I'm gonna be honest the
thing the things you're logged into will drop your old connection in a minute
a bit or a fucking bit or
exactly thank you knock turn me there's no way I'm saying that right knock turn
II knock turn ye for the this artwork of me and gamm gamm together and it was
drawn by chose my hand okay I'm hacking in I'll just turn into yeah okay I don't
think I'll bother playing the coin game I'll just turn into a yeah a because yeah
that storm is freaking violent and it just there we go there we go hold on
hold on okay right right right there we go there we go all right all right all
right oh the panic when my PC shut down I was like I was just trying to spin
the thing are you guys okay I didn't worry you too much did I pinned it in
chat now there is a storm going on and I freaking called it I called that the
storm was gonna fuck me up I knew it I knew it was gonna mess me up I don't know
hold on I'll see if I can I'm gonna take the filters off my microphone I'm
gonna see if you can hear it hold on right can you hear the rain against the
window I have no idea if you can hear that yeah you hear it yeah it is right I
put the D noise back on so it should be a lot quieter I predicted even storm
finds you irresistible where the storm shagged me the shot the sky he shagged me
I'm sorry there is a pink cloud in the sunset rain ASMR stream honestly in the
night I don't I think we're just gonna do a yapathon so don't be afraid to do
any marshmallows we'll do a yap I think she's coming on later I'm so sorry I
don't think my internet is stable enough I think if I boot that up again I'm
unironically gonna jinx it and now is she be played and what's the game's
name oh I don't know if you hear that the game's name oh no she isn't streaming
today oblieza that's it bring on Jen three right now she was off today yes
yes just a normal non-member stream ASMR not true so I do the deal is this the
point the game specifically she's oh she's not feeling too well nice bird
does get me I will promise I will extra feed the birds just because of how
terrible the weather is it's been awful right I'm gonna drink my tea now let me
drink my tea but hydration check the storm that shagged me sounds like one
hell of a parody the first marshmallow hey
strongy let's have a contest and see which can hold out longer my tongue or
your sanity winner tops loser I have great news for you depending on if you
want to be on the bottom fantastic news for you refund how about you know I just
put the hell of it let's put copyright free rain in the background rain is that
actually copyright free copyright music no not rain and tears no like actual
rain copyright free free video footage no copyright right no get that out of
here no copyright sound effect it's only a minute long I'm not looking a minute
long no one's got one hour rain no copyright fuck it I'll do it myself are
you serious copyright free rain ambience royalty free rain it's a minute
long babe what is going on bed aren't you supposed to be Royal Library I'm
praying this isn't copyright I'm gonna fricking cry I can't believe you copyrighted
a single teardrop in the corner a teardrop we bet yeah actually some got
copyright for rain before I take it back I said we're just taking the filter off
the microphone how can you copyright rain I suppose it's cuz if you went to
the effort I can't find one YouTube link that's copyright free fucking rain
am I the man I'm a good friend I'm turning into that zombie cat and I'm
turning into that zombie cat should I put a big ol like thing at the top of
OBS that says I can't my internet is insecure don't know what for it's a
bitch thank you the baby lord you can't cover it strong as copyright free rain
ambience sense is just sticking her microphone outside and literally opens
window and record do you remember thank you I really hit those notes there
master we'll turn into a thing you hi strongy we should snuggle to the sound
of storm and work on making gen two and three now when you say work on gen two
and three reflin are you being naughty are you suggesting something speaking of
being naughty guess I got the confirmation email from my website that
rings with bad madam and guess it has their hobbit Lego set on the way I don't
know are you squiddin me stash power I don't know thank you for the extended
membership stash for well now I know why breathy ASMR is not allowed some a whole
probably copyrighted everyone's breath and how stupid copper is being oh it's
been hound in the girls Azura and she be in particular been getting picked on by
the false copyright strikes and the thing is so you can reject it once if you
take it the next step and you can get a copyright strike
abuse meant if you take it a step further and be a beyond oh my god I don't
have a voice I was nice knowing yes sorry there's only so much estrogen that
was gonna let me hydrate sorry my voice is absolutely done I loved playing
overwatch with you's I looked back at some of the footage oh my god I was
screaming at certain parts I was reaming an excitement playing with you it was
suggesting mama direct with you get on the bed we are making a family why do
we call it family restroom it's the perfect time to shag in it something
something but I'm serious oh my soundboard isn't up goodness gravy let me
get my soundboard obscene deck is it streamed it or streamed it that's it
there hold on wait let me redo the joke let me do it everyone pretend I
didn't say the joke right Brian right hold on let me set it up again right
Brian you go I won't be suggesting mama I'll be direct with you get on the bed
we are making a family do you want to know why they call it family restroom it's
the perfect place to start family
fine be that way I can't believe mommy neutralized I don't get it a family
restroom as in like you can start a family and family as in mother and
husband and children and then you and then you start a family in the family
restroom because that's where families are supposed to be so you can enter as a
couple and leave as a family was it wait am I did I fuck that up is that not
make sense that is it can you provide an example my visual learner I don't know
why that started maybe boxing but there's your example all yours my mother and
father mother and husband play the crickets again stop it okay there you
go just for you I still don't get it but I love you and that's all that matters
thank you so see we friends have sense around here eight hours of sleep makes
you so get it I don't I'm just happy to be here literally got ten hours of sleep
and I'm gonna well if my internet would like to well my internet died but my
power also died so you know I had to play dead by daylight there for a
millisecond even though but it bounced back on its own but yeah I didn't say
anything but when I was playing the arcade my light was flickering and then
the PC died face there isn't enough power forget trying for a family
let's try for a baseball team under score how how many is in a baseball team I'm
too I'm too European for this 26
Colker faithfully I've got five plus six plus six what's that and mass it is 17
I've got 17 in the chamber that's all I've got nothing else they were good the
gents are gonna start walking out of my fanny if we go beyond gen 3 okay there
there's no labor there's no contractions they're just gonna be popping out once
they're done okay you forgot the substitute players we can't have enough
have you consider getting an APC for the power outage so I've never had an
issue with storms before genuinely haven't I don't know if you've seen the
footage on TikTok from Melbourne and but like yeah there's like lightning
strikes in the city and all that and people are like trying to get around in
the fucking wind is like blowing them over and stuff and I am a storm that is
approaching provoking black clouds and isolation I am reclaimer of my name born
in flames I have been we need someone to play against the other team we need
someone to play I make the other team more no I can't spawn the enemy team as
well that not someone else that Vila is gonna need that responsibility I
substitute Azura look I'm saying is Azura gonna make a good mom M&S 188
thank you for the super chat and motivated oh it's a song Virgil now I'm a
little motivated okay well hold on I've just activated fucking sleeper agents
what's just going on I've just activated oh it's a devil me cry song okay I was
gonna say cuz what just happened what I just I all you start coming up with the
same thing I'm like getting a sleeper agents have been activated we need a
whole basketball league or baseball league well that's still bad baseball leak
I'll make it happen leak as in all the the teams to like 12 teams so 12 times
26 no I think my nips will be brown by the end of that unfortunately um I do
nips okay you know what let's find out once a pro do nips go back to being pink
after pregnancy we must know the truth I'm here for the education we'll need some
fans I make the fans stop this is get this is too much sometimes that will go
back after pregnancy but not always some women may experience permanent changes
to their after pregnancy such as an increase in size or a change in color
additionally genetics can play a role to the extent of the changes after
pregnancy what a strange thing what a strange element and thank you stash
power for the baseball league suggestion I don't think it's happening and thank
you mum a little for the fans I can't do with blinks confused with blue are you
planning on doing any karaoke streams then um yeah I broke my voice but I
might be able to hold on let me finish my tea I need to come up with the song
haters and commentators I've got that covered hey I know who would come into
I don't know how to commentate we see them some fans we need a few million at least
I'll get it done look I know you've got two tentacles okay that can be used for
that explicit reason no no my whim can't take anymore it's too much it's too
much it's too much thank you tiny spainy and thank you stash power you've got
two tentacles but it's too much it's too much honest question mom if you were
regent in three becomes more successful could you imagine you go further okay I'm
gonna say something that is very truthful and very honest and you're not
gonna like it so fj into and three are successful and the consensus is we'd
like more the truth is I would probably not be streaming to focus on their
success I would be pulling strings in the background and doing that kind of
thing and I would still continue to make audios and community audios in
particular look like a worn leather tote bag after we are done the way I told
a worn leather tote bag we need multiple stadiums filled no anti-gen for well so
there is a bit of a little asterisk on that one dredgen karma thank you as well
fucking millions there isn't our asterisk I miss you already no refund
don't puke and there isn't asterisk to this if I can find people that know what
to do that that get what I need them to do that changes everything okay so
there is another vtuber that's a manager what the biggest problem I have right
now is I have so few little people that I can give access to the accounts to
that's the major thing so we've got an audio manager that's actually should
have came in yesterday but I've been lazy and not written up the the script
that they're supposed to follow basically and so there's someone that now
deals with the patreon audios and no longer deal with us during spring and
summer producing about 100 to 300 eggs oh come on we have to make an audio about
that and pregnant all 300 of my eggs thank you cartoffel of doom and no gen
for we need strong streams just like vtubers and famous companies again
whole stadiums all the world needs to be a fan seven billion minimum I'm not
replacing the fucking population rate sauce but it should come down I'm not
replacing the birth rate thank you mom alone only to the egg leave first and
but yes the what I'm facing so I have someone trustworthy that I can give the
patreon accounts to because and you know they have history experience I've already
worked in the field all that jazz so now I no longer have to deal with the
patreon stuff when it comes to managers this is different the managers are still
gonna have to go to management but I'm like slowly getting out of it so I still
deal with some stuff like and you know Mercy's got a project on the way I'm
kind of dealing with the artwork in that that's not a big thing to deal with like
ordering artwork isn't a big thing to deal with do you know what I mean
whereas when the manager comes in the manager can give advice can give on the
spot like do you need help or something but the manager doesn't have access to
accounts because they're a manager they're not supposed to have access to
that stuff and I don't have people that I can have on the team and have access to
their accounts does that make sense because there needs to be a safety net
yet the like managers have to go through management okay and it's very
difficult because if the girls need something but then that's when you can
start arguing well because the girls are so independent they do what they want
on their schedule they get handed the thumbnails the schedules the shorts they
just have to give us the shorts like the clips like you know when we say thank
you for clipping the girls that's because they take your clip and then that
link goes to an editor and that's it do you still use Marshmallow yes I do I've
always used Marshmallow and I took a break just because I was getting shit
but it's completely completely back to my my own stuff so Jen what 2034 and
Jen to debut in 2024 Jen what 20 more yet what you want me to stagger the
fucking a debut by fucking decades would be we would be it we wouldn't even be
relevant but we'd be gone sorry I don't want to have you to stop streaming now
you're fine you heard it she's single-handedly fixing the decline in
birth rate real yes because infinite strongy gone reduced to arms yeah you're
fine and it's very hard so I do have enough editors but I'm gonna need I think
two more reading the humans and well you've changed my mind I don't want to
kill all of humanity I just want to kill the high table thank you the very Lord
you two will be gone before we get Jen three brah better hope not fucking
cheeky bombs let's go gambling oh dang it is there something that keeps you from
being accepted from the clipper program and we don't know I've spoken to
management about what the yield is on the clipper program I actually don't
know if it's gonna get paused and just because I'll need to speak to management
about it there is something going on that was like and I can't remember what
the note was sorry I'm not and like I'm not in the clipper program discord or
anything like that it's management a yeah I can't so I'm trying to see if I can
find a note about it I don't know if it's gonna get paused temporarily it just
because we thought there was gonna be a bit more yield from it and obviously we
had like a base fee and the $2 per 1000 view thing and obviously the purpose of
it is like obviously it's to be very thankful towards the clippers but at
the end of the day the bottom line if we want to cut past all is to get the
girls like more views more and eyes-on type thing congrats on 25k by the way
thank you can I borrow your Tango for no particular reason yes speaking of going
gamble I just want a lot of money at the casino this week now I have more funds
to throw at the donut on you gambler to throw money at donut on John Omney young
man do not gamble gamble in video game don't come but in real life spank you're
gonna lose it all it's addictive you better be safe holy bait no don't
congratulate on you're making it worse we plan you're encouraging him we'd
still be here for you no matter how much time yeah I know it's a bit selfish but I
would love for you to stay with us for as long as easy peasy easy peasy not a
problem with me not a problem with me and thank you John Omney for the extended
membership and stash power as well easy easy let's go gambling now you're
encouraging each other to come but don't fucking gamble I need to take a weekend at
Vegas and turn 50 to refillions for mommy no keep your money spend it on a wee
bakery item for yourself it's like a nice thing your YouTube membership has a
24 month badge is that indication of how long you're gonna stream oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah and so the plan is I'm gonna stream every single day for a year I've
officially hit the three month mark thank you for the idea I was running out
of savings for the Donathan I'm booking a flight to Vegas as we speak a reef
land Calcutta I'm gonna spank you stop it hmm why not law big wins cuz it's
rigged against you imagine if there was so you know how they're like oh we're
gonna guarantee there's a winner the guarantee mommy's leaving I'm gonna
puke no don't pull it I'm not leaving I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying to see so
obviously if we're actually talking if you want me to be real for a second to
like talk about the behind-the-scenes stuff if however I can find people that
can take over kind of the shite I do in the background now hold on a minute what
happens if I just swim for three years and oh wait sorry management clipper
notes the cost is up the views are down that's the management I just got sent to
me okay there you go clipper notes the program might be getting paused when I
say paused I don't mean it's getting cancelled I mean it's right everyone
pause we're gonna pay you for what you've done we're gonna let it tally up and
then we're gonna open it up again at a later date okay that's what I mean when
I say pause we only have 21 I'm gonna be here for a very long time
let me be clear I absolutely love being a cuttlefish I love it okay the way she
says Cocker reminds me of my grandma Cocker are you trolling have I been
trolled no don't puke I'm gonna have to clean up so much after the stream don't
don't puke and the worms ate into our brain wait no finally made it why are we
puking we have three years make it count Cocker I barely even know her oh fuck
sorry that was supposed to be a pause sorry there you go not drum roll
now we're all scared stop it no stop I never said that oh my god you're taking
me out of context stop it wait cuttlefish only live two years what does that
mean no you're gonna pick yourself so ill wait we have three years but no no you
don't understand she's leaving Danny you show you my schedule for next week for
fuck's sake we're playing out the ring next week I can't remember the other
game yes I can't remember the other games I can't remember the other games I
can't remember the other games I'm playing next week wait this is the last
no you're being so stinky you're being so stinky I'm sending away that clip to be
edited of Goku and Vegeta I just need to find the Vegeta clip to send to an
editor I'd be like Scottish Scottish non-weep pronounces anime names Goku
Vegeta well and I ever knew she likes getting shagged by the storm better than
you technical are you gonna get free flint's brain worms over freaking rain
outside my window right now we only have two years left time to research age
prolonging medicine no black text and white background coming right but I'll
tell you what's on my schedule wait I'll see if I can get my team up hold on that
okay I have good news oh my fellow Americans okay I have good news we've
got two Elden Ring Streams on Saturday and Sunday so you can stream site me and
come play with me okay a we've got the Titanfall 2 campaign we're gonna play
that together she be put me in the mood I have a collab with none other than
baby pink peaches and sin sister on Castle Crashers I have an anime watch
along which is vivi fluorotide I song I never said anything that I've been
meaning to play this for a while so the game seems to have Martin is currently a
storm right now so we can't even play it because I think my stream is gonna cut
away any second is that why most of the time you don't sleep well because you
want to make most of your time for us shorted life span you stop that Castle
Crashers good game how do you pronounce cave-in
even scaven scaven I don't know sin pink and peaches love yeah silly anime
pronunciation many it's all being recorded don't believe their lies it's not
being pre-recorded or that insinuates you've just pre pre donated mini key
Rick carrot mini carrot sounds like a carrot you bag on the first week wait a
minute pre-recorded your mom in bed last night pop up pop up pop up pop you had
it right the first time if cuttlefish have a shelf life of two years then we
only have one and a half left you are gonna make them be sick stop winding
them up that's it I'm wait I'm typing in the spank of moat and chat right now
hold on let me pull up chat oh I'm allowed to leak a collab I have guess who
messaged me guess who messaged me yesterday for a hypnosis collab oh that's
me it begins with secret and ends with subject secret subject
message in spite stop puking Jenna no I didn't ask me for a secret subject ask
me for a hypnotic I'm like yeah you mean something I don't have to write for
once she kept me in yeah literally our paranormal yes paranormal as well
secret subject secret lab chair no secrets and sister subject no I'm at all
levels of people in our love will help us out live mama you're doing me a
concern tell me everything is gonna be all right and I'm actually giving your
brain work okay I'm sorry reeflands you know how truthful I am I wouldn't say
something if it should worry yet you shouldn't be worried though then you be
worried that thank you the beauty Lord don't be worried right no more actual
actual factual before anyone does get brain worms don't be worried I wouldn't
tell you anything that would worry you anyway like in the nicest way I'd rather
bottle it up and not tell you if something you should be concerned about
because I get so worried about you's worrying honestly you and paranormal
stream in a childhood game together we've got hey um I don't think there's cool
up childhood games well that's the problem we just love you so much we
won't worry we'll just cry no that's not even any better mommy would keep
secrets only two years left and there's not what do you mean only two years do
you know the YouTube play buttons go like play buttons the YouTube and membership
buttons go up to three years and four years and five years I think now this
is the part of the stream script where strony gets annoyed at the reeflings for
freaking out in the next five minutes something outrageous will happen no no
thank you tiny spainy no please get go online giya
giya online what's giya
too late we're way past worried we're crying stash power no reeflings stop it
giya
gemology classes online division what I've spelled that wrong
g giya online what are you
I have never in my life seen this then but I'm gonna be honest chief you you
play some really unique games fuck it mean paranormal Neil pitch right now
1v1 me scrub I will it's actually pre-recorded at the end time the end
isn't to get stalled it's pronounced Gaia like gynecologist alright excuse me
gynecologist collab coming for you here to hear first did I join as the streams
ending no I'm yapping instead and actually you know what I'm gonna put a big
text on the top of my screen that says I'm yapping true first cries truth how
it's correct momo stop it only two years call his deathlings only two years call
us deathlings are you okay wait that's really a pause and recalibrate you guys
like Danny what's going on I we're just teasing right you guys are teasing me
because I'm starting to like go on the concern side of things now
shitting and inking in fear right now underscore vomit underscore vomit lovely
I should have just kept playing the game honestly
two years vomiting face I just got here I'm starting to get a bit concerned are
you guys okay are you okay Danny put music on in the background and be like
okay I'm getting concerned now I'm not tea here and I'm like let's put legend
is there the look I fucking wall legend is there the look I copy it for you don't
worry about this strongy I think this is them just showing support with just a
mix of trolling okay right well then stop giving me money stop giving me money
then thank you very much wink a normal or wink wink 9000 basically whiz
groomed by the alert right okay no more trolling cuz you're actually getting me
concerned I'm breaking out in a sway I'm not being funny I'm actually breaking
out in a sweat cuz I think I've upset yeah I'm yeah let me take my marshmallows
mommy when is the heels like our extorting right now when the storm
passes actually I don't even know when the storm passes when does the storm pass
hold on let me look at the radar the weather radar oh I thought I was saying
there was a hundred twenty eight kilometer wind or something now that
doesn't look accurate at all and me I need to stop the stony second peak with a
reflet me no don't be a fuck is Jimmy be there not me be there like me was the
only talent I named correct that's all I'm saying she's the only one with the
best name that I gave everyone else got really scuffed up names oops thanks me
Jimmy biscuit why the fuck is she called Jimmy biscuit why are you calling my
daughter Jimmy biscuit what does that mean Jimmy biscuit would you even get
biscuit from to be honest it's just something to think about anything ending
it just looks to think that Jimmy biscuit I love Jimmy biscuit what do you mean I love
fondle of the bosom Jimmy biscoff
a third a thank you for the 10 gifted memberships maybe that will reassure the
refunds thank you very much a very kind of year
mm Apcoron thank you for the gifted membership as well congrats to those who caught them with
their face wait if Amy is your daughter then I'm your son so the lore runs rather
unique at viewer I birthed everyone from my loins with the refunds okay so the
refunds are your daddy but Amy is you still your wee sister so technically
you're my son as well and I birthed you right but as there is also the mummy of
humanity and birthed literally humanity and humans themselves so who says we only
have two years left ah the refund I said so what I said was they were like what
happens after 10 gen 2 and gen 3 they were like is there a gen after that and I
said look it's not possible unless you know I go offline and I get people into
help and then all the refunds start puking everywhere and it was a nightmare
they're still puking and I was trying to explain that I can't have any more than
three gens and I because it's just too much I can't handle it and then as I said
they're they're puking again I'm so sorry thank you again at 30 for the gifted and Apcoron
Alabama logic yeah pretty much the bullet so we're the father the son and the grandson
yeah you're also OG son grandson and the grandson yes stash power it runs deep okay
it runs the vealers end and I've only reached my three month anniversary
right yes are done I'm not touching the subject again wait that also means you guys were my parents
and Emmy and I hate you so Emmys lore basically you the brother are a delinquent and the parents
and Emmys lore are like religious and very strict very authoritarian very we're not your friends
we're your parents type of thing and obviously you little brother would rebellion but no big
brother were rebellious so you kind of like acted out in a sense that you knew they wouldn't be happy
with and Emmy loved you for that she loved that you were you know like in her eyes like her rose
tinted eyes you were the embodiment of the strength and determination and the resistance
that she wanted you say we're the father the son in the holy spirit honestly many correct
gazillionaire thank you for the 20 gifted memberships as well congrats to those who cut
the widow face um baby we're gonna make a conspiracy board to track the bloodline it's a mess
the the blood there is a mess the lore if you really want to get into it but um yeah and then
what happens is this is a bit of a hidden lore that's kind of been brought back up thanks to
em embers uh redesign um her book emmy's book is what got you killed um
i know that sounds really odd to say but it is that's how you died um
thank you very much for the gifted memberships echo as well are you guys where um why are you
giving me so much money hold on i need to shove this on top
there we go so anyone who joins knows there's a storm
emmy literally then emmy couldn't resist and it just yeah that was not my that was my pc not yours
oh yeah i forgot to say that sorry jeez apple brandy thank you for the extended membership
hello strunnion chat hello little hyena apple so emmy kills big bro no the book killed the
book belonged to big brother he rebelled against um his parents via the book of witchcraft wizardry
wherever you want to call it the dark side any of that pitch the book is what killed him the book
is what has him stuck in um purgatory if you will being tortured and emmy has vouched that she will
become a strong enough entity to destroy what holds him back and then they get their happy ending so
if you didn't know i have said this before but don't worry if you didn't know everyone has a
happy ending at the allure so if um for whatever reason you know i'll respect that decision anyone
wants to leave i will ask the girls to close their lore so emmy has a happy ending and gets her
brother no they do not biologically have any children however they do have happy days at the end um
azura finds her place in human uh no sorry aces happy ending only happy endings that this
felt real that's really sweet tragic why not why are they not gonna have children go look up that
spanish king and tell me why they're no having wings okay they love each other they don't need
children okay they love each other yeah children we are big brothers uh everyone's
uncle and grandpa good morning good morning glad to give you that lore basically with
wait more velour leaves um actually the herdsworth are different no what i'm saying is there's gonna
be an ending to the stories if anyone leaves they're gonna be seeing mama's happy ending soon
that's a bad ending for us what not right you guys are off on you're gonna actually give each other
brain worms manually we are gonna do it manually so like mersey's ending was so when she first got
attacked her her pupils split into that broken heart because mersey can't have appropriate love
right now because of the state her brain is in so in order to fix that broken heart when she
she wraps up it's gonna the pupil is gonna become whole again i don't know how to make it whole
again i thought it would be really funny if mersey got like hit on the head or something
in combat and then like it all clicks together and then she can like love appropriately again
um like uh she be she be just wants to run the hotel um you know she does best running the hotel
and all that sew it back together again honestly it means leave it now right i'm changing the subject
you guys are gonna seriously by the end of the stream you guys are gonna be like actually feeling
sick two years call us desperately jokes aside we all love you and we just we're just trolling
don't worry about us we just cry a lot okay i'll stop we really love you please don't worry we love
love love love love i'm changing the subject because she's are no getting it yous are winding me up
honestly science shows that i can have honestly science shows that you can have one generation
of wincest and your kids have like a 98 percent chance of being fine
atherna a atherna a oh there is let me say to ourself no no wanes only breed
atherna a god damn have you fallen to your knees for your little sister
next you're gonna tell me you want her to call you slurs what the fuck what the fuck
you know pin pals have been saying that in my fucking things um the brain worms are wiggling
too much stop the brain worms are wriggling so much as i stand on soil i'll dig to the center
of the earth and perish no wink wink nine thousand no it's not a hundred percent it's fifty percent
fuck it out we've done our research emmy pops up everyone started furiously typing into google
searches what's the percentage rate of the child coming out messed up when it comes to ms188 thank
you for the thingy the thingy the topa chat atherna a i have to admit how you having those oshi
marks while saying that out loud is uh very brave that was you're literally the man standing up in
the courtroom meme mommy please insult me no i almost got in trouble last time i didn't so it's
almost said the r word is this about my little sister can't be this cute anime uh yeah i totally
didn't did i don't have a gen me at all that was given a very unique lore stands up i want mommy to
grieve me trawling i'm puking from every hole in my little reef body what you looking at
what you looking at nothing nothing tell me i'm a good boy well pat in my head you are a good boy
darlin you are a good boy do you want to praise and praise and affection ASMR uh right today's
agendination i actually need a message in me you know that you look sexy you little sexy minks
i i read your message but i didn't reply
i
right there we go i've messaged my little sister
pop pop pop pop pop wait what strongy wait a minute you're you're a bro con your sis con
i mean if it's in me and she is
okay let me read my my email don't read on stream
uh real and true uh i think we see you long thoughts on having a watch along of the sonic
game fandoms while i play that everyone says play the shadow the hedgehog shooter if i play
the shadow the hedgehogs i miss my wife tails that's the only quote i know from it i'm back in
the fucking building i know that one too grapecuddles strongy wants to grape all of you no i wouldn't
grape emmy what the fuck no i do nicely look i'm a massive fucking bro i might not have the
i might not have the appendage but emmy does thank you i said what i said um
um
but emmy wants it
i don't know i feel like i feel like mentally if i even even if i knew even if i knew i feel
like mentally i would still take a toll on me it would be like one of those things where
is everyone a viewer i mean it's my kind of thing all right what what do you mean you don't
like giant tests a little cheeky bore sometimes a little bit more and you know
lord of the rings power season 2 is out as well i saw that lord of the rings anime i saw it but i
didn't watch it but i saw it came out giant test time to go spelunky they did surgery on a grape
we grape you we grape you grape we all grape
em hey mummit can i lay on you to cuddle up against you and fall asleep while it rains so
we're both warm and comfy yeah i think that's cute there's only one way to stop a crying refland
is our word in aftercare i think that would work honestly that might work
i'm gonna have so many kids with mommy she'll have permanent memory loss except that the only
thing she knows is that she loves me and her children that's kind of sad i made myself sad
wait what how can you have can you have memory loss memory loss from having too many children
it's not real i know your brain chemistry gets altered when you do have a child results indicate
that having three or more children has negative effects on late life cognition
who the fuck wants to get pregnant please be so for real right now
other than me i'm gonna get that manga sheet paneled uh shebe's getting some oh no i can't
say that don't don't leak what i just leaked there okay shebe's getting some artwork don't leak it
though it's for her birthday it's for her birthday don't leak it i shouldn't have said that
but he's full happy it's a little treat five children already
so good at leaking you do it unintentionally i'm surprised what if shebe's lurking lurk i assume
she's in bed because she doesn't feel well right now it's her day off so assume she sleeps in
i have no idea what time is in america i'm gonna be honest
strony holland what does that mean wait mommy got gonna get bad health no
uh with this storm outside there's only one thing to do let's plop on every surface of the house
and work on overpopulating the planet real hello hi you mentioned on the card tcg stream that you
were sort of interested in getting into magic of the gathering you also seem to enjoy the cute cars
and things which means you might want to poke at magic the gathering arena it's an online free
to play version it takes care of all the rules and can be free to play if you're willing to get
walloped the most relevant part currently is the current set is based on the world of woodland
animal crows so all of them are cute rabbits i don't want them to fight animals maybe it's cute
maybe it's cute girlfriend confesses hypnotizes you to forget the confession oh i like that that's
a good one thank you stealing your ideas they're my ideas now all mine uh yes tonight tonight's the
night the mood is right all i really do is babe um i am going to work so ac is gonna have a youtube
role play sheebie is gonna have a youtube role play emmy i'm gonna meek out with no i'm not
that's sexual harassment um i um i don't know if i want to say that maybe i'm gonna help emmy do
something clip no don't clip that what the fuck if you clip that everyone's gonna be like i knew
viewers just sexual harassment agents there i knew sorry i'm rubbing my eyeballs right now hello
hr department i am hr oh my god someone should do that like i should i'll commission that where
it's like i'm doing something bad to one of the girls and then i'll walk away and then they get
hr on the phone and then it's me on the other side of the phone looking really devious watching them
in the cctv footage and then strongy you know it's no simp september i've never heard of that
wait more than three gents is bad more than three pregs bad but she birthed 25k reeflings oh no
hr should be sheebie and she's just slicking herself and the the meme
and a patrick star voice can i make out with emmy i mean
i guess hr shall decide your fate i am the hr ace my idea hr lady takes it
you can't say that parallel but yes i do want to do that um april first vealer exposed exposed
as they honestly i don't know if strongy or sheebie would well the i swear sheebie had a stream
and they were like who's the worst and vealer and everyone was like strongy and i'm like
honestly that's fair i did spawn him like you know i think we might have made a bit of history
in terms of hey why did why did gen one look like gen one oh it's all based after my personal interests
yeah i don't think many people can say that how much did you spend to get your special
interest developed quite a lot yeah i kind of just said fuck it honestly pretty wasn't sheebie
in office lady hr fits her she was but she was a jet i think it's called a desk jockey where you
just work at the desk all the time all the time a small loan of 60k how daring already made the
investment back but you didn't hear that from me oh my god vealer more like the failure investment
made back in three months that's terrible it's terrible can we get a sneak peek at your schedule
yes um it's not made up because i need to swap out coin master so i don't actually have my perfect
schedule but it was there somewhere that information's mine she be the desk jockey as opposed to strongy
yes i don't know if i'll make a short about being like things people said about the chibber agency
i don't want it to be like a boohoo negative short i wanted it to be like people said this
about the agency they said it was gonna fail and it's like surprise after three months we already
made the return on investment um because i really yeah people were pretty fucking nasty when we
booted off i'm not gonna lie uh a lot of like uh gonna be unsuccessful gonna be this gonna be that
the one of the things was management was gonna run away with the money which i was like you
did not have a fucking clue who's behind the scenes do you then if that's your fucking take away from
80 20 split and all that jazz i'm like fucking hell fucking hell they're like you know what they
sound like you know those managers that post there is like this meme post that went viral and
as a manager and he was like i just can't get my workers to be motivated and everyone all like he
got bombarded and was like are you paying the minimum wage do you only pay the minimum wage so
you only did it i was like you give people minimum wage and a little tiny slither of how much they
earn yeah damn right they're not fucking motivated to work damn fucking right you could have you
could enable them as much as you want if they're making fucking pennies on the dollar yeah damn
fucking straight they do not give a random fucking shite so okay okay they do not care
right i've got a bit more of uh now this schedule isn't uh let me be clear this schedule isn't
complete because it's not finished can i do that i can't see it right put it in the bin then put it
in the bin put it in the bin you didn't see that it's me being lazy i'm just trying to drag files
into a thingy so i don't have to import it oh let me be transparent this there we go okay
there that's a bit better it's not complete but the elden ring endurance back to back starts up
i started on the weekend to give weekend but it also goes into monday so if you're a weekend worker
please don't worry minimum wage minimum effort boss makes a dollar i make a day man that's why
your shit on company time sorry i'm slapping my whole war ball if you can hear that um
vivi's gonna make you cry wait is it gonna make me cry is it a crying anime i thought it was a fun
anime um i'm also gonna do possibly if ac isn't streaming i might do a member stream at ac's time
slot does that make sense maybe i might do the ace more members at ac's time slot and then swap
something it just depends vivi has pretty crying moments oh god am i gonna need a box of tissues
for that stream um but yes castle cashers collab i've got baby pink peaches don't sing the peaches
song that per girl gets it enough and then sins is through so if you aren't sick of sin yet she's
showing up on my channel um ace more stream is going to be the
workout one i'm going to be working out day and night uh the lonely stoner seems to do his mind
at night shone makes a dollar i make a day and that's why i piss on sweat twit is a lot honestly
tropic thunder though good um sweet sweat asmr honestly it should be called sweat asmr but yes
the asmr milestone stream is going to be taken to there and i don't know what to do for a needs
game though i kind of need a shorter day shorter game when i do like asmr swams
uh so the titanfall 2 campaign six hours
need a game two hours maybe uh i'll actually play coin master properly on that day because
i think the storm would have passed by then um anime watch along is six hours because it's a
12 episode anime so you got six hours of me then castle crashers and then it's that's a four-hour
day ace more stream um members watch along tropic thunder yeah someone recommended tropic thunder
i've never seen it before so i hope you're ready for me to be surprised the only meme i know is
never go full r please don't stream titanfall 2 for as long as she did i gave up on clip in that
stream because it was eight hours i have played titanfall 2 so um she be you have to remember
she be playing sure it's for the very first time she she said herself she doesn't normally play
categorized games like that it's the first time she does that and she probably played medium mode
or something whereas i play easy mode and just blast the campaign because i like the stories and so
um has any riefling brought up the elden ring seamless co-op mod 500 rieflings can join at a time
i think that shows ip unfortunately whereas elden ring servers and i think it's actually kind of a
bit i don't know if this is wrong of me to assume i actually think it's nicer to have a smaller team
of rieflings when we do a challenge or explore do you know what i mean
um you didn't we have to watch it you are um i think you guys might like the more intimate
like team aspect to elden ring yeah i know i know oh my god the eldering devs didn't
want it to be that way yeah guess what guess what guess what you know what you know what sound
effect you're getting to that
yeah that's right you're getting feral's cursed have you heard of a game called click holding
i saw it and it's really weird crazy jesse thank you for the super chat it's really weird i saw it
so a few v-tubers played i was like so it's a guy sitting in a chair and you have a clicky like
click click click and you're to click on it and then that's it that's the game
it's rather scary
made to the dev of that game is that shifting sand land yeah titanfall 2
i don't think more than 100 rieflings have elden ring today 500 rieflings would also probably
crash your game turn the slab um but yeah it's a pretty strange game yeah i saw um
thinking my barber from idol n planned to play it i don't know if she did play or not but i saw
the name of it and i looked up the game because i was like what the fuck is this uh my yazaki
actually like seamless co-op and is considered in co-op in the future for elden ring
i just like i just want to hang out and play game okay controversial but yes we're going to play
elden ring um we're going to pick up where we left off last time we are in the dlc the last
area we are in the dlc is um the flower area and we never killed the snake blood guy yet
iron scar thank you for becoming a member um but we didn't kill the the snake guy yet i'm
gonna have to remember how the frick to play the game because it's been a hot second i also
need to level up my weapons apparently and i've like not leveled up any of my weapons so i need to
be good and get ready my yazaki is the director of singing ah so we fight in mesmer i think so
we got so close there is this reflin uh duo that got so close um unfortunately you guys are
going to have to be the ones to carry through the game i still don't even know where the boss
fight in elden ring looks like in the dlc yet um her japanese is so cute is it japanese if i'm just
trying to name someone and i suck so badly um but yeah uh i'll try and pick something at least
days some r stream will be exciting because i'm jumping up and down playing ring fit as well
and i'm basically gonna make sure i'm awake and had something to eat before or else i think
i'm gonna be sick like last time i did that because i don't i don't know what to do about the
shower though because the shower is gonna be so loud i just feel like the shower is gonna be like
it's supposed to be asmr wink wink but i think i'll put a big thing at the top of the screen
that says don't listen at asmr volumes obviously when i'd like to do it's gonna be loud like
it's just a just an audio live of me having a shower ring fit don't overdo it this time
no i'm gonna do booty workouts again though because i love the leg exercises i hate the arm
ones i hate arm ones you're getting a shower yeah i'm doing one hour of um trying to silently
work out basically so it's just gonna be heavy breathing asmr and then i'm gonna go into the
shower and then we'll probably talk for like 30 minutes and then i'm gonna take a break and then
we'll we'll watch tropic thunder to calm down the strongy butt must get bigger better to hear all
the water drip on your body well it's gonna be like so echoey that's my only thing it's gonna
be like so loud like um yeah but when you glow but mummy if you only train bottom you'll end up
like a t-rex ma i give up on my arms and my wrists and my hands they're so weak i just give up i'm
not even bothering to try and correct it or get more muscle i just yeah i give up right how do i
no don't pin it to me oh shit stuck in my hair get out rifa did your ink on
you stuck into my hair get out of here sticking that to my hair your ink your ink gets everywhere
my little noodle arms yes i have noodle arms get right plop plop plop get right um a story about
my uncle is a short game someone says wife husband hey strani please read this to yourself
no no i don't feel pitiful uh you know mumma if the storm is loud enough no one can hear you cream
we can be as loud as we want
oh wavelength should i try and open my window so you can hear how bad it is
hold on let me pause the music i'm gonna see if i can open my window to show you to show you
oh i'm just like are you squinting me right now i don't know are you squinting me right now
well you were supposed to swallow so not my fault where did that come from at thank you the
bit of the month snake your fucking wiggle i've taken the filter off hold on you're gonna hear
like so much more bump in there i'm gonna see if i can open the window or if i'm i really hope
there's no neighbor because they're just gonna see me a buck-ass snake you're trying to open a
window right now this is me lifting up the paint oh that's the one right is this gonna work oh
oh there's birch show you on the window when did that get there
can you hear that
can you hear it or is it not that loud
i'm not sure you hear windy you hear the wind in the rain
yeah of course it comes down when i open it so it doesn't look that dramatic it's cozy maybe i
should just record it from i want to hear some more rain sounds okay i close the window again
i put down the blame so no one can see me the buck-ass snake and then i'm gonna put the filter
back on so you don't hear all the bumping because i do so much bumping like on stream i bump everything
right thingy filters should sound a move but there's no windy but it's peaceful
visiting your girlfriend's house till it's storming outside and her parents are home
you plop this hard between the lightning strikes bro how much lightning jinx got to be in the
background sounds like a hurricane when i used to live on the coast yeah that's a free way it's
free real estate me being the first one to come out with a copyright free ring
okay i sit back down
and adding to the magic the gathering matter you should also take a look at yugio gx
come on get your game on there's a bunch of waifu archetypes like the dragon maids go on then
let's type in dragon maids yugio gx dragon maids yugio yugio
let's see the colors shapes and colors oh there's five of them
oh that's cute goyne oh looks like kai from idol n one of them with a color scheme a bit
mm gx is the anime dragon maids don't come out no when i lived in tectas they had one storm
that spawned a tornado a few miles away from where i sat bro and shit myself i want to be the
reefland that rides on top of your head that way i can tell everyone that thought okay i'll put you
on my head how about that let me grab a reefland hold on how do i keep losing my folders i'm not
laughing anymore give me my goddamn folder where's my reefland oh at one no we're not tinfoil hat
today hi mithan right let me look straight ahead my poppy right there there you go hi mithan
it's us
i got mixed in the corn folder real
there we go hi are you having fun up here boingy boingy boingy boingy boingy boingy
bounce bounce bounce bounce bounce everyone turn that front upside down reefland
mommy we need a happy reefland ah have a picture of you happy
everything's crying your hair smells nice yeah can you smell the lush bar
i've been using jump in juniper oh see bounce see bounce
a what do you think only the tinfoil hat reefland is happy wait i do have that file
oh it is this is the only happy one i have is there enough real estate i'll put you in my
hair uh you're you hold on to me via your tentacles okay you're not going anywhere
i think happy reefling was on deck for an emote but i hasn't yes i'm waiting until
that but emote batch oh no i do it i've got another week to wait i thought it was today
because it said nine and i remember the ninth is when i'm getting handed the emote
reefland the the ink glue that's holding you in my hair
and if we're allowed to recommend movies for a watch long i'll suggest awesome powers i think
you'd really like it yeah i've never seen it before i'm gonna uh i will watch it with you is
100 percent oh yeah the bath one is smiling i do have the bath one i guess because it's
rainy it makes sense to have you oh my god that's so cute hold on let me
oh i need me to get a little bit smaller there we go oh no you're you're in my tip of my hair
hold on go into the bunch there you go in in the bunch of my hair grab that hair like the
handlebars that they are yeah you finally discovered why uh i like my double bunches
better be pulling on my shirt
you are so cute look how adorable you are
do you like any drama movies um i don't really watch movies i don't i don't mean that as
in a quirky like i don't watch me i mean like i just don't like i don't have time so i get to
watch things at the same time like with you which i think is actually really nice because normally it's
you know i'll watch things that are familiar or
sorry a reeflands just sent me happy reeflands hold on i'm getting more on board climb aboard
babies okay you go there and then i'll bring your twin in and you go there for no particular
reason we're so cute together wait what happens if i do this
there we go oh one's really swaying on that tip
irish ones you having fun
we
i'm so cute i'm so cute i love it
did you get good sleep i got 10 hours so i'm ready to work for the girls i'm a i'm a air
map 20% today thank you to the reefland that sent those png reeflands for me and not making it too
hard some people send me a link and then they remove all the dots but you only have to like
break up one door right yeah we'll be on tv yeah that does everything oh i need to do my i need to
update my alternative twitter as well with all those artworks i got of us oh i'm feeling it mr
crabs oh i might do it after stream you know that
i think i'm gonna do it i think i'm gonna do it
never to see artwork locked in the hard drive it's too bouncy i'm gonna be so do you need to
take your anti sickness pill oh do it you won't yes i uh i think there's like five artworks i just
need to make up my little captions with them which i'm gonna more happy reeflings
there's more pictures of you being happy and not crying and puking everywhere i swear if i end up
seeing a pinterest the the reason why i say that every time is because someone sent me like oh cute
reefland and it was their pinterest and i was like look you're not wrong that is what you are i just
didn't expect it i just didn't expect it okay i got a wee bit prank just a wee bit right let's
put you in my bunches down here and then the new one
oh yeah where'd you go
that's that's where that sounds like halo
did he draw a face on it no i was just straight up his pinterest and i was like yeah you know what
that that is what reefland is at the end of the day
uh where is this one theory oh no he's not png that's okay look it's on par it's on par for
him not being a png right okay boom oh my god this is like a uh mary a fat wait what are you
linked to oh you're on my shoulder you're not you're supposed to be in my hair there you go you
swing it's a void link yeah my vision story has more sad reeflands than happy i'm starting to
suspect you want to keep us sad i milk the sadness out of you that's what happened
um yeah i can't wait to show my artworks because i have more variations of reeflands
in them aim there's there's an artwork where three of you are tag team in me
so i'm gonna write the wee scenario for it i think i'll write it about me being stressed and being
like that's it mummy you need to de-stress reeflands have had enough and then it's three of you's
tag team in here
my jealousy right now aren't you a reefland or are you not reefland
hi johnny hi missy mummy needs correction more variations yes i'm gonna show you more variations
i need to see if i can put earrings on of you although you can't really see my ears but i have
a little bit of a point to my ears um the girls are gonna get new ref sheets soon actually which
i'm really excited about i think it'll be very nice and easy and i think i'll be an easy commission
for the artists as well because we already kind of have established looks in that i just need them
slightly more detailed slightly more detailed yeah that's why i saw those got the reeflands
pitch and tentacle yeah we're being wholesome this stream this is like the most tame and relaxed
we've ever been we're just yapping um but yeah nice and calm and all is calm all is quiet i've
sent back the notes about the velour video game so it's going to take around two weeks to put in
my notes because there was a few things missing um there's even a hidden reefland the one that
went spelunking i'm not being funny i'm so tempted to commission the alternative like outfit where i
have your tentacles wrapped around me i'm like what do i commission first because i'm getting
mummies getting h word over the concept like oh i can just see it now like the tentacles wrapping
around my thighs and my hips and my stomach a little uh give me it smash smash smash smash
give me it smash smash smash smash see that reefland right there me which one am i pointing to yes
exactly blah blah blah i'm a vampire reefland that would be very hot this is the part where
i'm a bad influence and say commission them all no i want it i want if we do have alternative
outfits that come out i would want everyone to have it at the same time because i don't think it's fair
to like now it's different when the girls want to you know like after a year the gloves came to
come off um because i have like taught speaking of three on one this is safe to open on stream
are you commission what hello
oh uh you know what it is safe to show on stream
it is safe to show on stream
this is not my commission though but
make it a bit smaller look it's three on one yeah are you massaging me get me nice and relaxed
get spanked get spanked up yeah i pop all week because i don't want to get in too much trouble
i was definitely three on one though
you don't have to use this reefland just wanted to share it while you're looking i'm currently
looking at all on another one from a movie that's safe though what are you sending me
and why is it not a picture of your pinterest
oh my god reefland
i guess i would need to put you on my shoulder whoa why am i lagging
don't i keep thinking my internet is about to go out you have you belong on my chest because
you're calling me that's quite a few reeflands oh my god i'm ready to commission another one
hold on a minute i'm ready to commission this and this and this and this
so do we all have sucking caps under our tentacles that don't ink oh yeah you you can
you have passive so you have passive ink that comes from you like
that makes time easy for me because
tight and you also have suckers if you want to use them but you're able to like flatten them
to stop the suction and you can grow at your arms they so just because you're small you can
actually grow your arms to like extend if you need to reach something or just something with them
for no particular reason um yeah this is amazing fast all those funds are getting used oh yeah
she's having ideas i love how it's so much you've thought about the lore oh the lore runs
deep i needed i need the tent oh i mean i need the reeflings to have to enjoy their lore
yes
scraping those hard to reach places honestly reefling lore update so then we could suction cup
hickeys oh you want to mark me hi arielle i'm so sorry fucking i saw your tweet arielle
about being like i'm literally little mermaid or something i'm so fucking sorry i'm i pray it's
fucking said ariel or ariel oh god i'm getting it wrong i'm getting it wrong finally caught you
live hi how are you darlin hold on let me give you the spammer the spammer the wrench and the
hammer the spammer there you go i too am somewhat of a professional spammer myself hope you're doing
good it is fine honestly um no i saw your tweet and it was like everyone calls me like ariel and i'm
like to me you would call you ariel especially since you're so pale we need to mark you give me
hickeys the reeflings are currently flirting with me so uh don't be don't be too surprised with the
shenanigans we get up to in here um ariel raid oh i need behave hi i am aware that there is a five
minute subscriber countdown thingy but thank you so much for the redirect and the raid i appreciate it
i'm strony cuttles from generation one in dull dread for your lore um and my name uh i am having
unfortunately it's very stormy weather and my internet and power shot out earlier oh as you
literally just heard my house rattle if you heard that um so i'm just yapping um but thank you so
much for the redirect that was very kind uh unfortunately i'm not appropriate for younger
audiences so if you find yourself to be younger you need to skew yourself away somewhere else
because i don't really talk about things that are appropriate oh i hope i can be it can be
soft so yeah it's a storm unfortunately so i'm taking the l i'm taking the l because i can't
really do too much about it um but i'll probably give this game a yeah uh a chance again a good
yeah get a little cheeky yeah don't mind me and i'll follow you on twitter ariel hold on i'm just
checking right now you do yeah we follow each other okay good go good go uh are you squid me
i need to make sure make sure we follow each other finally called strony cuttles stream
she spent three hours yapping before lightning blew up her power grid live on stream great entertainer
she is i finally get into the game i do like one machine it's over it's over give the game a yeah
literally i will i'll probably give coin game another shot again though because it is a pretty
decent game like you can do a lot of stuff um i apologize for sending this meme don't apologize
let me analyze let's see what your meme is oh your meme it's so hard right now don't worry about
raiders being young arie was calling us old oh are you og suns any og sun oh arithlyn made a meme you
want to see it how many generations did you want again how many uh how many gents did you
want again from villa yeah you're in this they are old og sun yeah there you go there you go
as i said cuttlefish can lay 300 eggs in a clutch so you know you pop me on some of these medications
it's over it's over i like that meme 10 out of 10 i should i should do a meme review oh my gosh
because you guys are so creative with the stuff you come up with like that one that one meme where
we're in a classroom and i'm thinking about marrying you and you're thinking about something else
now what happens if you take a pill each time that's not a meme what's that
someone sent me a picture of a tentacle and they put a cute refling
you're done it's got a suction cup to it though
um
uh right let me see hi mummy i know you've already talked about your donathon
but um as you're a donathon had a hundred dollar and fifty dollar rewards are there
similar rewards also what are the rewards for those top three um i am going to go over my
donathon rewards again because i wrote those before um velar even popped up because i was
guessing what i needed so it's getting completely thrown out the window and redone um i will warn
you uh it will be posted in advance and we kind of messed up with azura's post a little bit
um and didn't give much warning to what the rewards might have been
um but what we'll do it differently like sheebie's is coming up um sheebie's gonna like
warn in advance and i'm gonna do it as well um and you'll see what the rewards are um
um the the membership stream i did do talking about donathon rewards a lot of them are so outdated
like i've already done them so don't worry too much they're getting changed up we'll do another
donathon membership to try and iron out the kinks um you don't need to read this out loud
aw you look so cute with all the reflings me cuddling yeah yeah you like when we're all together
you swinging off my hair swinging off my um i think you might get even more support than azura
i'm just glad that she can start preparing to move out obviously it's quite a big thing
as far as i'm aware azura hasn't moved out before on her own so it's the first time
she's ever doing something so it's obviously it's going to take a while um but she's like slowly
already working on her rewards like i'm working alongside her to make sure the rewards get done
in a timely manner um we were so obviously she's taking a bit of a break right now um but when
she comes back she's basically walloping the absolute living daylights out of the donathon
like every stream's gonna be like yeah get wrecked donathon plop plop plop plop plop um we if you
donated on azura's donathon to the sum of $50 or above please check your emails uh management
is messaged you we need we need information from you to to get your rewards adequately
give 50k donathon reward life extension medicine for the reflings you guys look so nice
is there a moving out as hey that is yeah azura was talking about what uh what she had to do
quite a few things before she moved yeah like to prepare to move out for the first time as a nightmare
like i remember when i first moved out oh my god i could freaking beat my dad up so badly um
huh he was like just i think what he he never said he didn't want me to move out but he was
being so awkward trying to let me move out but i think what it was is he didn't want me to move out
um so i was like i was legit crying having to carry like my own pc into this flat when i was
like so weak like i smashed my pc against the wall basically because i was so weak trying to move it
in because my dad refused to help me get out the car um oh there you go management we're
waiting on 12 people to respond regarding azura's donathon yeah um we're gonna have a cutoff date
if you don't reply after a date azura is just gonna move on ahead because basically we can't
progress with the azura's um audio rewards until people respond so we're gonna have to have a
cutoff date because azura is gonna have to start getting to work so please check your emails if you
were uh did there's been a tweet from the twitter account azura mentioned it on her stream uh we'll
get her to mention it on her next stream as well because um we're trying to get this wrapped up
in two months i'm gonna ask the girls to really we don't want any donathon reward issues put it
that way um i want to learn from the mistakes of others our history is bound to repeat itself
you know come on you 12 bleeding hearts hi scrawny hi mithlyn when my parents threw me out i was
really down it's hard alone yeah like ma so i got a flat and my dad so my mom couldn't help um but my
dad was my only mode of transport so i was like i want to move out now i don't care that there's no
internet i want to move out now like because i was really i was having a lot of issues at home um
like i love my mum i'll always say that i love loves my mum but i cannot live under the same
roof as her um we have very big personalities okay um and i couldn't work i couldn't do anything i was
constantly getting interrupted i was constantly getting woken up by her um like i told my mum
stop opening my bedroom door it wakes me up when you do it and every day every fucking morning
she'd wake me up opening the door um i don't know what it was i don't know about some control
thing some weird thing i pleaded with her i work at night i have a waitress job i am exhausted
stop opening my door and she'd always go oh scrawny it's to let the cats in your room
no i'm sleeping oh my god sorry i'm getting triggered thinking about i just remembered that
i would beg and plead let me sleep do not interrupt my sleep and every time she'd open my door
um love my mum but i'm no i'm no living under that roof for her again lover scrawny your shadow
box and no i'm not it's real she used to open my door and wake me up okay take the key and lock
there's no locked doors in scottish households unless you make one um basically it's very
uncommon to have locked doors in the uk the sandal can't hurt you anymore it's okay scrawny the
orange sandal i know for those of you don't know my mum used to hit me with an orange sandal and
i celebrated when i broke get fucked orange sandal my mum is top heavy and mummy's bottom
heavy and dad is doing some material what the fuck the whole cutler's family's getting in on this
um yeah thank you groomed by vealer um honestly matt as i said my goals are all kind of agency
related um or in some way it will be fed back it's not like i need to be able to afford to move
out or anything like that i already moved out surprise surprise surprise it's all i've got an
eyelash in my eye just need to remove it ow ow please don't stab my eyeball please my cornea will
someone please think about my cornea health okay there's a lot of sins mum gento is my favourite
ptsd sandals under ptsd where doors open in honestly i i completely forgot i used to
plead with my mum to not open the door i just remembered that and i'm like yeah i'm moving
out was the best choice of my life um my sister had a habit of opening my door without warning so
in the uk there's not really a knock on the door policy like you know how like knock knock come in
is all shown on like american tv shows that's not really what um that's not really what what's the
word what happens in the uk like that's not commonplace um but i remember i just remember pleading
and she used to always look at me like strani i don't know what the big deal is i don't know what
you're talking about and i used to be like like she used to play dumb and obviously i would raise
my voice because i'd get really angry i'd be like you know what the you're waking me up in the middle
of my sleep cycle like she just didn't care or she just used to play and then oh my god one time i
remember i really raised my voice because i had enough i was like i don't want to be here i don't
want to live here anymore um like i'm fucking moving out because my mum was so resistant to
i was like i need to move out like fucking now i was desperate i was desperate to move out and
one time i raised my voice because i was like because you fucking wake me up all the time um
and she like acted all shocked like i could see in her body language she like pretended to act so
shocked when i shouted and raised my voice because i don't normally do it i never do it um but like
she was me fucking listening to me i was like you interrupt my sleep i never get sleep
because you can't you lock your doors no there's no locked doors
and then when i moved out obviously our relationship got like fucking 10 times better
because surprise surprise it was on my own terms no accountability no like as i said i love my mum
but oh my god sometimes she had some funny ideas like yeah damn umar oh my god i can't say that
umar umar abdulla thank you for the membership please enjoy your emotes i'm not saying that
umar umar i don't know how to say your name but anyway i'm out i'm out i love love mum mum
can't wait to see your next but not doing that again mummy reverse of the collar wifling wait
you just made that right wait hold on reverse of the collar wifling where i'm holding the leash
oh my god this is so cute oh my gosh wait hold on
is that gonna work i don't know if that's gonna work
i'm covering up the all i'm covering up the other ones right you guys are gonna have to
move to my shoulder okay oh my god that's so cute oh no this wait why are you not that right
we'll make you my earrings how about that you can be mummies earrings and then you'll have to be
on my shoulder how about that what do you think it's so cute i love it
stronti have you seen this meme before let's find out let's find out have i seen this meme
i swear if it's authentic can i even show that uh right fuck it let's do it let's do it
are you ready for this meme this is starting into a meme review hold on let me put myself over here
meme review wow she's i am not smart but thank you for the compliment
is this real is that what you actually want to do why is it not god i want to go spelunking
someone make a god i want to go spelunking right now that's lore accurate literally real mid okay
i'll trust you i'll trust you
spelunking in the lung that is unironically kind of real your gap is very attractive i mean let's
face it with cheeks like tears are drawn elsewhere spelunking yes spelunking means to go in a cave
apparently but it sounds like something else we need a reefling with a mining helmet and a pickaxe
i'm going spelunking that's actually really good only the facts real and true
hold on let me enolize is anyone else coming on today is emmer's coming on
oh emmy's short almost got 500 half a million views on emmy's new short yeah damn emmy
yeah is emmy doing what are you doing today emmy is not screaming today uh azure is offline
shibby's day off and then mersey might be playing with cork
mersey's coming on at 9 a.m real and true early mersey stream early mersey stream
the pleasure is all main
mersey's playing with what oh there's this game she plays it's called cork and i'm like why are you
okay right we'll redirect into mersey
yeah this is chill um as i said ac and shibby are gonna have a new role play out very soon
if i can get it if i can wrap them both up shit they might both have a new one coming up
and i might have one of them too have you heard of the ai song the reefland made yes the one that was
like strongy spelunk it wait hold on hold on wait pause the tunes i'm putting some ai on real quick
oh the hair you spell chauffeur ready
down in the ocean where the coral shanes break a little fish named strongy that's full of light
big old behind and a plant in her mind a new reefland's happy one ink at a time
um we got a factory with sun to the sea where the reeflands come to ink and they do it with glee
and they do it over the handsway and she's straight and some cheer sun is making magic and the reeflands
draw near it's so cute and swim and all excited and proud pay the ink up in the factory
going to guide swim through with a wink and a grin and they leave her factory with a mile within
the strong got a factory under the under the sea when the inklings come to ink and they do it with
glee he's in swing and he's spreading some cheer shaw and he's making magic when the reeflands draw
near it's so cute with the colors run true strongies factories place where dreams come true
we got a vast of ink and every shade in you and the reeflands know that you'll take care of them too
strongies got a factory of best under the sea where the inks just come to ink and they do it with glee
and the big swim swaying and spreading some cheer shaw and he's making magic and the reeflands
draw near the river you're driving with an ocean so wide and the brownies factory pride inside
with a babe behind shaking the fert so free shaw and he's making joy in the inky sea
I want to make it a real song though but am I gonna get obliterated because it was technically AI
is it I don't know I want to make it a real song though like it's so good
like literally way down in the ocean where the coral shines bright lives a cuttlefish named
she's got a big old behind and a plan in her mind AI has no copyright you don't get I mean
the AI can't go no like I would get this song like custom produced and all that like I'm not
gonna get in trouble for that because that can be like well a reefland made a plausible deniability
lyrics by reefling though it was written by a human just composed by a machine yeah like that's
what I was saying I don't understand how the machine knew my name and like that I have a button
so if you cover it yeah like I was gonna get a different like temple made for it
and like I wouldn't make it country I would change it from country to like maybe like pop or something
way down in the ocean where the coral shines bright lives a cuttlefish called scrawny and
we're inking today like I would get it changed to paul I am yeah heavy male version way down in
the ocean where the coral shines bright scrawny gates them through with the wink and a grin and
they leave her factory with a smile within I like the lane about how I have different shades of ink
where is it uh a heart so free was really cute that was a good one as well where is it
it was like different shade I've got other she's got vats of ink in every shade and hue was such a
good one do it it's literally AI you can do what you want no but what I mean like I want I'm gonna
get it turned into like a me a song I think that was so good the only problem is I need to tell the
producer hey I have no vocal range can you make it like how I'm supposed to say it that'd be great
I have zero vocal range I have zero vocal range all the day all the day all the day
whether it's AI art that's cringe no like I would make it human does that make sense
so it's not like someone's job got yoinked um like I only like AI art for the memes like put me
in a wheelchair wait no that that sounds horrible out of context that sounds awful out of context
there was a AI artwork of me in a wheelchair a very long time ago okay under the sea um that
sounded terrible out of context don't actually put me in a wheelchair it was to do with my health
because I was having health issues I mean like you know you know how it is um this meme is from a
member stream but you might not want to show it I don't know oh my god wait but what happens if the
memes via member streams is how we is how we show our thingy I don't know yeah fuck it we joke about
it all the time fuck it fuck it I had a mistape oh it's attached to my face I had a mistape okay
how is that miss input miss input it's going in the bin it's going going oh my god
why is it so dramatically flashing it's not real that never actually happened in a membership stream
I haven't in a more of me in the water I haven't how do I display this meme
can I drag it
right get off the screen what the fuck
I forgot about the ending oh that was from my audio where uh
clap my hands in the ASMR I'm so sorry I forgot I saved that meme
sorry I forgot I can say sorry for trauma dumping in your mirrors no it's fine
don't be silly I didn't read it out loud because I didn't know if you wanted me to read it out
loud so I was just like I'll leave that between us I asked this clip of things of hands yes I get
to reupload it and on the 19th on the 19th I get to um sorry I don't I don't know why I did that
please forgive me I didn't mean it that way
do
I totally forgot about that clapping stream are you sure you want to wish me
well so I got done for the breathing I never actually got done for because if you listen to the
audio it does just sound like I'm running around like a maniac and just breathe in and it's like
well I can't really get done for that can I I've been flashbinding the best way are you gonna teach
the other cake top jimmies to clap with no hands um I don't know how I would go about that I just
kind of discovered I could do it so the way I discovered that I could do it is I would I would
take a shower and then before um I got out the shower I would kind of like jump up and down a
little bit like I wouldn't lift off the ground and then like obviously you can imagine my surprise
where I was like oh yeah what the fuck was that when it clapped for the first time and then I was
like oh my god I can clap my cheeks um because that's how I used to get the water to like jump
off of me and so yeah uh the heart attack I got when it echoed in the shower for the first time
I literally I was like who goes there identify yourself and I was like literally my own butt cheeks
um
so yeah that that's the story of how I discovered I can clap my
I can give myself a round of applause um domain expansion malevolent backshot
wonderful mummy I was feeling slightly tired but the hearing the clap of your hands woke me up
fully and I'm now energized oh yeah you all feel the energy so can you please say order thanks
no I'm trying to unlearn it I'm trying so bad to unlearn it a standing ovation honestly who's
not literally who's at the fucking door I don't remember ordering a package who's at the door
um
we're in the danger we ordered your brain roll we want your brain roll those stumps who cannot
be knocking out my door and it's literally me clap them uh hydration check
um right is this the part where I make terrible terrible terrible news
shawnee can you please say order
order
had to boot that one up um right I if I make it a short stream today I'll make you a deal
she be an aces videos go up and an asmr one from me as well how about that
uh he's stretched okay I stretched okay deal yeah so snowberries harem and of course my darling
reef um uh Azura might also have a very unique coffee past on twitter going out later I wonder
what it'll be I'll also see if I can make it into a short um I'll see I'll see the stream
isn't as long enough that you're done well so don't pressure yourself I feel really bad my
streams have been so short this week obviously it doesn't help that um a tomato ketchup packet you
know but they've been so short literally look at my streams this week
uh one hour hypnosis one hour do you think like mummy
three hour watch along two hour dungeon crawler two hour gas station two hour kill it with fire
two remember asmar then it jumps to nine hours on over a gee I wonder why I was so motivated to
play that game for such a long time hmm and then it was four hours yapping on tcg and then two hours
again this is such a short you streamed overwatch for eight hours yeah but I like it's different
because I got to play with the reef it's so different um like it I just like it's such a
short week from me it feels almost strange but I do know that it's gonna change like next week
we've got elden rings so I'm getting takeaway sorry but I'm treating myself to take away during
elden ring I'm getting a hsp I'm getting a mac as breakfast I'm gonna fuel myself for them elden ring
streams two hours is fine it just feels wrong you know like you know when you wake up and you're like
something feels wrong today it feels off that's what it feels like feels wrong um
and the captions deal yeah yeah there's gonna be subtitles in the girls ASMR videos
um for the moose par yeah um it's still more content than many other streamers do so didn't
feel bad such a short week streams less than 100 hours in a week that feeling is being a baller
you stream every day it's fine we're thankful oh tours is generally normal for streamers am I
normal to you what did you just call me normal me in this house I think not
I mean shit I'm literally getting piled on by the reason
honestly short streams are better for productivity that's why I always say it's an exchange
sent strongy what you send me marshmallow oh sorry
no no I mean you're not safe for work all right hold on let me put that in my nose
let me put it in my notes uh let me be clear I'm putting it in my notes right now not
alternative twitter not the other word alternative twitter captions go you slag and then a little
kiss you honestly do you know I'm just gonna screenshot my notes so you can see this is
what my notes look like that was me that was my pc it's not your pc it's fine that was me
okay crop file say bad this is literally my notes right
um this is what my notes look like I just have a discord where I put all my own stuff in
can I find the screenshot because it always goes up it always disappears right there we go I found
ready boom this is what I it's just me like rambling into a discord don't attach to my face
like it's just me rambling and into a discord that's it I'm just like here's my notes like
literally I just that's what I just wrote right now yes it's 6 a.m alternative twitter caption
go you slag girlfriend hypnotizes them I'm just happy to hear your voice honestly love you
oh thank you like I'm just happy to hear your voice honestly love you mama oh thank you crazy jessie
but yeah like literally this is all my notes like torture lobot me girlfriend forces you to stop
pheromone maxon obviously I can't spell properly but yeah that's that's supposed to say ASMR behind
the scenes shorts and then apparently I just went a bit german slash Dutch and shorts
really I ASMR doing opi young literally shorts but yeah that's what my notes look like when I'm
like I'm typing a note to myself that's what it looks like it's just chaos
thank you dr look how am I supposed to even say that dr look Edgar von leist cleansed
oh I tried I'm sorry I can't do it man I just can't twist she doesn't realize she's rambling
into the girls disco I've done it before where I've dropped a note for myself in the gen chat
and had to delete it because I'm like wait a minute you're not gonna know what the heck is this
hey story probably not suitable for a stream read
you made a movie no pressure to read but if you have time you made a movie a vealer
how could you what
vealer the movie generation one indulge
we fade into the great barrier reef underwater as we see a new day dawn as reeflings begin
waking up and peek their heads out the tall grass and what
act one how many acts are there
reflin what act three
oh my god how big is this wait I'll put it in gen chat
uh we got a movie script oh my god sorry I put it in gen chat low
how have you done that scrawny denies that this isn't what she wants she wants men to also be
respected both the cabal and the slime girl have the wrong end of both extremes the slime
girl say that it's pay oh my god am I fighting slime girl am I fucking hate slime girls to
unlock the sealed room there's what the fuck we should I'm gonna make an AI read it and we'll
make an AI read it and we'll listen to it together hold them 10 000 words what the fuck my regular
scripts don't even reach 2000 words and you bang out a 10 000 word uh
one of the most adorable things about some people what accents is our word in between words that
end with an a and the words with I is there an umbrella in the closet umbrella in becomes
umbrella in umbrella I found the fan for myself get Brian on it no AI read it all this is so
on the throat 10 000 words it's sore you need to give me extra ink if you're gonna make me read it
keep pacing
movie refling done going to work on another let's say so one really quick
hmm what have you sent me
actually while we're on the subject of tentacles
he's so cute when did you become such a cutie patootie you're stealing my heart oh my cover
are you ready for the movie with mommy yeah you got your popcorn oh my god your retentacles
go over the bucket as well you got a wee soda you got a wee cola a wee fizzy juice with your
popcorn did you get butter popcorn the the other salt popcorn or something else popcorn oh he's so
cute what the fuck is this I have I have fun designs for gen four velour smegma an albino leech
girl who loves cottage cheese
refling what are you smoking a scat girl fly monster girl who's addicted to
refling I ain't reading no further the fuck is this
a smegma girl are you done
there's more birth the girl's model would change each stream over nine months and the chat would
be displayed as an ultrasound monitor I'm gonna need you to not cook for the next 15 minutes
refling and look in the mirror and think about your actions because they have consequences you've
now put that in all of her minds okay a fly girl scat vtuber why never cook again look in the
ntr smug guy who uses other clearly visible men to support her assets like afro deity and legend
of rock and ragnarok what game is legend I've not played legend of ragnarok sorry I don't understand
that reference what the fuck what don't fucking cook again you hear me
you burnt it you burnt it it's a manga oh I thought it was a video game it sounds like a
video game he went to cook and ended up turning it in a charcoal search afro deity and ragnarok
okay hold on
no duck don't go not you image she's oh she's the one that had people carry her boobs in that one
screenshot I was gonna get that drawn as a zero
yeah that's her
maybe I won't get that screenshot drawn at all when I've chosen ntr
mommy your management is there a way to reach out if I had a donor but didn't get any email yes
use the website use the website message the website with the email you used with the donor phone
to prove it to you um you'll be one of the 12 we're waiting on
better hurry arzur is getting arzur is getting i'm steeped she's ready to do these right
she's ready to do the rewards makes him to be a fit a dwarven girl that stands on a step ladder
that's just mean that's mean
oh all right I'm trying to get the one on my head in the frame too
hey stroney just one last mile before I go sit pant bark good girl sit I'm sad
that pant
bark
I feel like my bark is too deep arf arf
although I think I barked for sin I think because I was so hyper in game that I didn't care
and I was like but I feel like my actual bark like when I'm not there is like arf arf yeah
overwatch does that to you you did bark for sin barf barf average roofland
are we gonna get an alternative skin for puppy stroney do you want it the management should
probably send a final warning so what's gonna happen is if they don't come trickling in there'll
be one more tweet done and be like azura needs to start working on the rewards because it's holding
everyone back like I don't know I'm like I'm like there is there was some feedback management told
me there was like um someone reached the milestone to get a reward for something and they were like
nah I don't want anything I was like oh what a fucking chat excuse us they're like no no we
don't want any reward well I don't want nothing and return for the money I'm oh excuse us we didn't
realize we were dealing with such a chat over here um so yeah what a monk honestly
gives his worldly possessions nah I don't need anything in return okay thank you
damn boy you put the loudest fuck haha I don't know for real I think you're cool I think that's
pretty cool um what about cult of the lamb unless I missed it that's getting redone on a different
day because yes he just wanted Azura to move out he got what he wanted real and true
okay are you reefy reefland I just realized there's no music playing
are you reefy reefy are you gonna be okay if I start um heading the good news is Mercy comes on
very soon um very very soon and the even better news is ASMR from me ASMR from AC ASMR for she be
a voice thing from Azura and Emmy is cooking in the background as always
that's my that's my my handshake that's my handshake okay in exchange for a shorter stream week this
week but ASMR another ASMR another ASMR I'm also gonna get management to make up the schedule so
you know what the themes are as I said there's now no longer any collaboration role plays
um that are gonna be on patreon because that flopped harder than something flopping really no
yeah that flopped harder than what you guys don't have any uh you guys don't have phones or whatever
it flop pretty hard yes Emmy the chef literally Emmy the chef uh do what you gotta do thank you
rare mercy stream on a time I'm not sleeping let's go yeah you're gonna get a chance to watch
mercy should I watched mercy should I watched any kind of yellow remember wait it flopped
people did not like the collaboration audios and that's partly my fault because in the VA world
it's like really good if people collab it's so exciting it's amazing but in the VTuber side of
things it's not so good so that was a clash of my knowledge I was like oh yeah this is gonna hit
and then a lot of feedback came back and it's like oh I completely missed a mark my apologies
my apologies have a good day uh love we shan't be doing that again um so uh Azura does have audio
collab public releases but because it's public release it's your option to consume it and it's
free if that makes sense so yeah um there's one-on-one collabs with everyone actually so
I'll figure out what plots and we need to do which one the baby pink no no no no
the patreon collabs won't I am like I did a collab with mersey I mean icicle were together
and chibi and Azura were together for an audio but people didn't like it and I was like oh
I may have missed the mark um
oh is this one of those things where the happy people are quiet
uh did it get um there was a few website emails a few on Marshmallow but none of them were rude
about on Marshmallow I never got any rude ones um but people made a fair point where it was like
I only paid to hear one girl so I guess that makes sense um it's part of the learning process yeah
as I said it wasn't nasty or anything like I never got any nastiness I just got this wasn't
what I was looking for and it was like okay now I know better so the collaboration audios will now
be like public access stuff or milestone stuff um because I kind of missed the mark without
but yeah some people are really loyal I guess yeah so in the VA side of things if two people
collab like people go ape shit it's the fucking most best thing ever and in the VA oh my god you
can tell that I've not got hands oh my god make that be fun bigger right now okay no wait go down
there we go I was like oh you can tell I don't have arms um I love the nurse one oh I'm good
to like it they complained about getting more girls well I can now just like it well as I said um
it's gonna be it it's not that there's never gonna be collabs again it's just gonna be public
access and what you pay on patreon you get only your girl from now on my immersion yeah I like the
mummy and stroney a collab you mean mersi and stroney okay in exchange for going off earthy
I will do one work okay deal
uh I don't know how many how I'll kiss you for how many reeflings I have on me one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten 10 reeflings one
and one for good luck
oh thank you so much for letting me yap away I really do apologize about my um pc
shutting down an internet this storm has been uh baroon for quite a while um and I fucking
called it I could hear it I could bloody hear the intensity I just knew something was gonna happen
um thank you for this dream no thank you for this dream thank you for hanging even though I'm
just like chirping away like a bird tweeting away um hopefully there'll be loads of updates
very shortly you won't see the ASMR until tomorrow before the girl stream time okay what I tried to
do is upload the ASMRs before anyone that is actually going to stream live because I don't
want it to come out and people are like I'm going to go away and listen to this ASMR and then come
back I'm like no you must watch my girls you must watch my daughters um so yeah they're going to
be all coming out at funny times apart from each other okay I love you I see you tomorrow okay for
some titanfall too oh yeah we're going to use the gatlin one that's the one we're going to be using
okay because I like the I like the feel of gatlin guns in video games right stop yapping love you
love you I'll see you tomorrow okay enjoy yourselves have a good day please enjoy mercy modis in t-minus
two and a half hours I'm sure there's enough ASMR content between all of us to keep you
occupied in the background huh and then you get to say kohaiyo bye bye bye I'll see you tomorrow
first I'm titanfall too